voilà les garçons de mon quartier
extrait du nouvel album de juliette
il s'appelle lutte cathy ce mois là pour
ça ça passe beaucoup et qui a aussi deux
duos sur cet album il y en a avec
françois morel qui s'appelle mémère dans
les orties il vous insulter copieusement
on entend certains se donnent des noms
d'oiseaux nous c'est des noms de
poissons ça y va
ah ouais la morue le maquereau enfin
tout y passe à la fin ils voudraient de
femmes de liposucer quoi ouais mais on
leur vole en fait on a fondé la barge
est sûre et parce qu'on avait une coda
de chansons que les plus longues que la
chanson donc un on est on est parti dans
la proue et c'était terrible hein et
bien duo avec avec guillaume depardieu
une chanson magnifique qui s'appelle une
lettre oubliée alors en deux mots c'est
un jeune homme qui écrit une lettre à sa
bien aimée ça commence comme ça par une
lettre sa bien aimée et puis très
rapidement on entend une voix de femme
qui est finalement en train de relire
cette lettre des années plus tard et qui
se souvient absolument pas qui est ce
qui a pu lui envoyer ça et c'est une
lettre poignante d'autant plus qu'en
avançant dans la chanson on s'aperçoit
que le garçon est en train de l'écrire
il est au front on l'appelle il est 5
heures et il va falloir y aller on sait
pas ce qu'il va devenir
en tout cas il lui demande en conclusion
de ne cite jamais il lui arrivait
quelque chose de ne jamais l'oublier
voilà raté quoi
je souris
e
mais qui ma foi
oh
royer
tu sais quel ennui
le roi
effondrée ou est-ce henry et souple
si beaux yeux rien dire et la folie
kim tour
le détour
c'est mignon ça n'a peut-être y
et
je le choix
je reviendrai travaux sur vos rêves
première fois
je vois
tous très posé
par lettre entre mes deux mois
tél
aussi
il faut faire
vu de pire
tu
c'est aller
je vais vous cherchez de man
deux mesures
passer tant que l'amnésie faut on
de cet amour
la c noyer voilà cette dame chance en
cadeau
et alors qui est extraordinaire c'est
que vous racontez le camp guillaume est
venu pour interpréter sa partie du duo
dans le studio tout le monde avait les
larmes aux yeux
ouais c'est un moment super émouvant lui
il s'en est pas rendu compte il est dans
la cabine une prise était oui c'est en
fait il y en a on en a fait 3 on a gardé
la deuxième parce que la première était
très tendue et puis il y avait
évidemment la découverte de la de la
musique de la chanson se jouera un peu
bas il faut se mettre dedans croire et
on a gardé la deuxième qui était
absolument magnifique tout en émotion en
fait
et puis c'est vrai que 35 e jocelyne a
commencé dans le studio
on était tous bon moi je le regardais
plus pour ça je donnais pas les départs
et c'était la rue complet on était tous
comme sens regarder plus on était
l'ingénieur du son il était payé la tête
rentrée dans les épaules et en été en
étant une émotion folk encore une fois
très émouvant pour moi guillaume que tu
que tu chantes comme ça ouais c'est beau
hein
seydoux et vous dites c'est un ange
c'est comme ça qu'ils sont les anges
ouais c'est les faits alors c'est vrai
bon ben voilà donc maintenant vous
faites des duos vous et des passages
radio de la pub télé quand vous n'êtes
pas du tout en bis bis contre votre
maison de disque jamais rien comme les
autres donc en fait ma vie tandis que je
les adore vous êtes prêté à jouer le jeu
donc c'est pas jouer le jeu c'est eux
qui joue mon jour est finalement c'est
ça l'idée c'est que j'écris des chansons
et puis elle salle aura bien plus sains
déjà les maquettes et puis voilà quoi
après je suis arrivé avec des idées en
dix ans j'aimerais bien voila j'aimerais
bien faire un duo enfin la roma